mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
i'm thinking of a sequence of numbers
this sequence of numbers has the
following properties
first
a2n is equal to two
multiplied by a n
plus one
second
a two n plus one is equal to a two
multiplied by a n minus two
if a7 is equal to 2
and a1 is between 0 and 1
what is the value of a25
i thank sean from south korea for the
suggestion
a version of this problem appeared on
the csat
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
let's first analyze a 25
by the second property of the sequence
a25 is equal to a2 multiplied by a12
minus 2.
we'll then analyze a12
by the first property of the sequence
this is equal to a2 multiplied by a6
plus one
let's now analyze a7
we know its value is equal to two
by the second property of the sequence
it's also equaled a two multiplied by a
three minus two
this implies that a2 a3 is equal to four
from here we can solve for a6 by the
first property of the sequence a6 is
equal to a283 plus one
a two eight three is equal to four which
means a6 is equal to five
we're making good progress on this
problem
we've solved for a6
if we could solve for a2 we could then
solve for a12
with the value of a2 and a12 we could
then solve for the value of a25
so let's focus on solving for a2
we know that a2 a3 is equal to 4.
let's focus on a3
by the second property of the sequence
a3 is equal to a2 a1 minus 2.
then let's focus on a2
by the first property of the sequence a2
is equal to a2 multiplied by a1 plus 1.
we know the product of a2 and a3 is
equal to four
so let's take the product of these two
equations
the result is the following equation
we can then simplify this equation by
expanding we end up with a quadratic
equation where the quadratic variable is
the term a2 multiplied by a1
we can simplify this equation
we can then factor into linear terms
we can then solve this equation we'll
get two possibilities
a two multiplied by a one is equal to
three
and a two multiplied by a one is equal
to negative two
let's further analyze these
possibilities
in order to do that
we'll look at a2
let's solve for a2 in this equation
we'll first subtract a2 a1 from both
sides of the equation
we'll then factor a two
and then we'll divide both sides of the
equation by one minus a one
now recall that a one is between zero
and one
this means one minus a one will be a
positive number and thus the reciprocal
of 1 minus a1 is a positive number
consequently a2 will be a positive
number since a1 and a2 are both positive
numbers that means a 2 multiplied by a1
is a positive number
we thus can eliminate the possibility
that their product is a negative number
and we eliminate the value of negative
two
we thus have a2 multiplied by a1 is
equal to three
we can then look at the equation for a2
to get that a2 is equal to 3 plus 1
which is equal to 4.
we can now solve for the value of a25
we first calculate a 12 which will be
equal to 4 multiplied by 5 plus 1 which
is equal to 21.
we can then calculate the value of a 25
which is equal to a2 multiplied by a12
minus 2 and that's equal to 4 multiplied
by 21 minus 2 and that's equal to 82 and
that's our answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time